okay so today's video is really going to
be just an overview of photosynthesis if
you're looking for a more detailed video
with all the specifics if you read in
the description box below there will be
a link for a more detailed video but in
this overview we're gonna focus on how
sunlight how rainwater and how carbon
dioxide from the atmosphere can produce
oxygen and sugars such as glucose so
let's get started
so the Sun gives off a variety of types
of energy and this energy travels across
space in the form of a wave and the
titles of the energy you can see at the
top of the picture now we're going to
focus our attention on visible light
because it's the wavelength of visible
light that drives and powers
photosynthesis
well let's focus on how light is
absorbed and when we do we're gonna see
that the Sun gives off visible light
also called white light white light is
actually a mixture of ROYGBIV and what
this is are the colors of the rainbow
red orange yellow green blue indigo
violet all these colors are a mixture
known as white light well how do we know
this because when you shine light into a
prism when you shine white light into a
prism a rainbow comes out the other end
just like you can see in this animation
white light is entering from the left
and because of the curvature of the
prism ROYGBIV the colors of the rainbow
are coming out the other end
notice how the wavelengths are different
red has a longer wavelength the violet
has a more narrow and so this is how we
know that white light is made from a
mixture of these colors here is an
actual picture of white light entering a
prism and you can see on the left hand
side a rainbow is coming out the back
end
you know moisture in the air can act
like a prism and create a rainbow
you ever notice after it rains you can
sometimes see a rainbow in the sky or in
this case narrow waterfall because of
all the moisture in the sky the moisture
separates the light the sunlight into
the rainbow colors that you see and so
colors are either reflected or absorbed
when sunlight shines on an object what
we see is reflected light the reason
this leaf appears green is because it's
reflecting the green wavelength of light
when light shines on these bananas the
reason it appears yellow is because the
yellow wavelength reflects well the
other color colors are absorbed when we
shine light and these balloons the blue
wavelength reflects into our eyes and
the other colors are absorbed when we
look at white objects like snow or this
arctic hare the reason objects appear
white is because white reflects all the
colors
and all the light all the wavelengths of
light enter our eyes and our brain
interprets this as the color white
well the opposite would be black when
light shines on a black object
nothing reflects it always absorbed and
that's why this automobile pairs black
because there's no light reflecting into
our eyes so when we relate this to
photosynthesis plants have you know
mostly green leaves which means that
they're gonna reflect the green
wavelength but the other colors are
absorbing into the leaves and are going
to be powering photosynthesis in this
graph we can see for instance that this
graph shows the wavelengths of light
that most power photosynthesis notice
how there's a peak around 400 nanometers
well that's the wavelength of blue
there's another peak around 700
nanometers well that's a wavelength of
red so blue light and red light are most
stimulating for plants in the process of
photosynthesis ironically the color
green around 550 nanometers the color
green that we most associate with plants
actually has the least amount of impact
in their ability to do photosynthesis
that's because most green light is
reflecting very little green light is
actually absorbing into the leaf so when
we look at a general definition of
photosynthesis you know it's the process
that converts solar energy into glucose
and this formula here outlines
photosynthesis and in the reactants we
have carbon dioxide and water and in the
presence of sunlight will produce sugars
such as glucose and oxygen well who who
performs photosynthesis well these are
the autotrophs now we typically think of
plants as doing photosynthesis but
they're not the only ones algae
phytoplankton the basis of ocean food
webs help kelp can grow into these
enormous underwater forests and even
some bacteria known as cyanobacteria are
photosynthetic so there's a lot more
autotrophs than just plants
so photosynthesis is also what we call
an end organic chemical reaction and
what that means is that photosynthesis
requires the input of energy from the
picture I'm implying that sunlight
sunlight is the energy that is input to
power photosynthesis and when we talk
about the end result what's created well
oxygen which is a waste gas and simple
sugars like glucose but when we zoom out
into the leaf we find some peculiar
pores on their underside these pores
will open and close and they're called
stomata and it's how they exchange gases
it's how they take in carbon dioxide
from the atmosphere and when they
produce oxygen as a waste through these
stomata openings they give off the
oxygen created so it's through these
pores that they exchange gas with the
atmosphere
okay so now we're gonna get into the
chloroplasts and the process of
photosynthesis because the chloroplast
is the location where photosynthesis
occurs and if in this diagram we have a
very simplistic drawing here of a
chloroplast sliced open so we can see
the inner parts and the first part I
want to draw your attention to is the
liquid like interior the liquid fluid
interior called the stroma you know kind
of like cells have a fluid interior
called the cytoplasm chloroplasts have a
fluid interior called the stroma notice
how I also just labeled one of those
disk-like structures right there the
thylakoid well there's actually twelve
thylakoids here in my drawing each disk
is a unit called a thylakoid and if you
ever come across the term Granum a
Granum is a stack of those thylakoids so
you can see in my total picture they
have three grana located or drawn in
this animation and so when we get into
photosynthesis stage one of
photosynthesis the light-dependent
reactions while like the name implies it
requires sunlight and the location are
the membranes of those thylakoids
the membranes being the outer boundary
so in the outer boundary of those
thylakoids
is where the light dependent reactions
occur so what I'm gonna do is just label
one of the phyla codes because I'm gonna
need some space for my animation and so
now we have some sun shining and after
all this is the light dependent
reactions so what sunlight causes is the
breaking of water molecules you know you
have to water a plant and so for a
variety of reasons well one of the
reasons why we have the water plant is
this right here inside of the thylakoids
there's a molecule of h2o water and with
energy from the Sun and various enzymes
that water molecule gets broken into the
height
toons in the oxygen well has another
water molecule let's repeat the water
molecule with energy from the Sun and
enzymes gets broken apart
notice how the hydrogen's entered the
stroma but what about the oxygens
well the oxygens actually bond together
and are released that's the oxygen that
plants will give off as their waste that
molecule of oxygen which we breathe and
we find life-giving used to be part of
an of a water molecule which i think is
pretty neat let's do that a few more
times so here's another water molecule
with energy from the Sun and various
enzymes that water molecule gets broken
down
here's another water molecule in an
asylum membrane and with energy from the
Sun and enzymes that water is broken
down and like we saw a moment ago the
oxygen atoms will bind together to make
Oh - that's the breathable oxygen that
plants release release as waste well
let's do that two more times
here's another water molecule broken
apart by energy from the Sun and enzymes
and here's another water molecule broken
apart from the sun's energy and from
enzymes and again the two oxygens bond
together to make breathable oxygen o2
the molecule that the the breath of life
as oxygen is sometimes called well what
happens next well what happens next is
in the thylakoid membrane there are
various enzymes and I like to illustrate
enzymes as a pair of animated scissors
so here's a pairs an enzyme right here
and what this enzyme does is it bonds
two molecules together a molecule called
adenosine diphosphate the D&I dies of
prefix that means - notice how there are
two phosphates that make up the adp so
the adp will bond with that single
phosphate and when they bond they make a
molecule called a
this energy molecule is gonna play a
very important role coming up very
shortly so now that stage one the light
dependent reactions are finished let's
just kind of check what's been created
some molecules of ATP have been created
bunch of hydrogens have been created and
some oxygen waste has been created well
let's go into stage two now okay so now
we're gonna move on into stage two a
photosynthesis called the light
independent reactions and you know
probably the first thing I should do is
remove the picture of the Sun from my
animation after all if this is the light
independent reactions then no sunlight
is required in this stage and this stage
will take place in that liquidy fluid
like interior called the stroma and
because it takes place in the stroma
just for our ease and to help direct
your focus I'm gonna remove all the
phyla codes for my animation in reality
of course they're still there but just
to help focus our attention on the
stroma
I've removed them and so what happens
next
is carbon dioxide from the atmosphere is
taken in you might know that carbon
dioxide is one of the main reactants of
photosynthesis and here's where it's
used the carbon dioxide is taken in from
the atmosphere and uh and the ATP
molecules that were created in stage 1
of photosynthesis the light dependent
reactions produced molecules of ATP ATP
along with various enzymes are going to
break apart those carbon dioxides so let
me go ahead and add a couple more ATP's
and let me go ahead and add some of my
animated scissors to represent the
enzymes and what happens is from the
actions of the enzymes and from the
breaking of ATP energy is released that
will break apart those carbon dioxides
into carbons and oxygens well look what
we have we have a bunch of carbon atoms
a bunch of hydrogen
a bunch of oxygen atoms in the stroma
well ask yourself what's the formula for
glucose maybe you know it's c6 h-12 o-6
glucose is made from a bunch of carbon a
bunch of hydrogen bunch of oxygen and
look what we have in the stroma we have
a bunch of carbon a bunch of hydrogen
and a bunch of oxygen so enzymes will
help to form glucose the atoms will be
brought together and we have a molecule
of glucose now in reality more than one
molecule of glucose will be created but
glucose nonetheless has been created
this process all began from the intake
of sunlight way back in the beginning of
stage one the light dependent reactions
but now we've seen the formation of
glucose you know what let's stop for a
moment and do a little bit of review you
know if we're in a class we're probably
gonna partner up for a moment but you
know at home try to pause the video and
and work on these six questions and when
you think you're ready to check your
answers hit the play button and continue
so here we go three two one you know
what is the fluid interior of the
chloroplast called well this will be the
stroma number two what are the
structures inside of a chloroplast that
actually contain chlorophyll well those
are the thylakoids number three what are
the overall products of photosynthesis
you know in a chemical equation like you
see in the picture here the products are
those listed on the right of the arrow
the products are what's produced and in
photosynthesis glucose or c6 h-12 o-6
and oxygen is produced and then number
four what are the reactants of
photosynthesis the reactants are those
on the left of the arrow the reactants
in this case are six molecules of carbon
dioxide and six molecules of water they
will react to form the products the
right-hand side of the arrow number five
what is created during the light
dependent reactions well I hope you know
there's three things created the three
things created during the light
dependent reactions would be the ATP
molecules all those hydrogen's and
oxygen waste and then number six what is
created during the light independent
reactions well that would be glucose
well let's go ahead and move on you know
before we wrap this video up I want to
discuss the connection between
photosynthesis and another process
called cellular respiration well in this
animation here if we focus on plant
cells you know plant cells contain
chloroplasts and mitochondria so what a
plant cell takes in sunlight the
sunlight will stimulate the chloroplast
to do photosynthesis and glucose is
created well what does the plant do with
that glucose notice in the animation
that glucose is passed to the plant
cells mitochondria the plant's
mitochondria will use that glucose to
perform the process of cellular
respiration in order to make ATP I have
another video that we can watch in a
little bit or at a later time to discuss
cellular respiration but right now I
want you to know that the mitochondria
is a job is to produce ATP and they
can't do that without the glucose from
photosynthesis but in animals it's a
little different you know here we have a
cow grazing and eating some grass
animals have to consume glucose from
their prey animals do not have
chloroplasts they don't have any way to
make glucose for themselves you know if
we zoom on into a cell from this cow
right here you know in an animal cell we
only see mitochondria there's no
chloroplasts so animals don't have a
means to produce glucose they have to
consume glucose from their prey so in my
animation glucose is coming from the
outside glucose is coming from the food
that the animal has eaten the glucose
hosts mitochondria and the mitochondria
will then perform the process of
cellular
operation in order to make ATP and ATP
is this really important energy molecule
that is really gonna power your cells
and we'll talk more about ATP in our
cellular respiration video and notes so
as we wrap it up I want to present to
you a couple scenarios to think about
and try to use your understanding of
photosynthesis so in this first one it
says bromothymol blue is an acid
indicator that turns a yellowish green
when exposed to an acid such as carbon
dioxide describe what would happen over
the course of 24 hours if you place the
water plant here's a water plant we
place the water plant in a bromothymol
blue solution and then let's say we use
a drinking straw and we add our breath
which contains carbon dioxide into the
liquid or the carbon dioxide is an acid
and bromothymol blue will turn this
yellowish green color when exposed to an
acid like carbon dioxide the reading
says the container is then sealed tight
and placed on a sunny windowsill what
I'd like you to try to do is pause the
video and try to predict what will
happen 24 hours later I'm gonna go over
the answer in three two one
well as the plant performs
photosynthesis the plant will begin to
take in carbon dioxide carbon dioxide is
one of the reactants of photosynthesis
and as more and more and more carbon
dioxide is used there's less carbon
dioxide in the water so the water will
slowly turn back to its original blue
color after all
if carbon dioxide is an acid and there's
no more acid in the water then the
bromothymol blue would turn back to its
original color so the plant absorb the
carbon dioxide from our breath and the
water returned back to its blue color
well I want to propose another scenario
to you next
in this situation let's say you repeat
the procedures mentioned in situation
number one we add the water plant we use
like a drinking straw and we blow our
breath of carbon dioxide into the
bromothymol blue solution and the
solution turned that yellow green color
it says only now you wrapped tinfoil
around the sealed container so let's
seal it and let's wrap some tin foil
around the container well let's try to
keep the conditions of the same so even
though there's tin foil we're still
gonna expose it to sunlight well
describe what would happen over the
course of 24 hours and why so pause the
video I'm gonna go over the answer in 3
2 1
well 24 hours later after we remove the
tin foil we're probably gonna see that
same yellowish greenish color after all
the plant did not have access to
sunlight therefore it's not able to do
photosynthesis it's not able to take in
the carbon dioxide so therefore the
carbon dioxide will remain inside of
that water and the water would stay that
yellowish greenish color because
photosynthesis did not occur
okay so there you have it there's an
overview of photosynthesis you know if
you're in my biology class try answering
these questions and I'm happy to check
your answers before class or after class
one day so thanks for watching